zweiter Gewinner der Wahl die überhaupt
ein plusergebnis hingelegt haben ist die
AFD mit 9,1 also +1,1 zugelegt Alexander
Kähler in Berlin kann die AFD zufrieden
sein man wollte ja eigentlich
zweistellig werden oder
ist genau die Frage denn in der Tat ist
die AFD von einem zweistelligen Ergebnis
einem deutlich zweistelligen Ergebnis
ausgegangen 2016 war das ja schon mal
14,2% das letzte Mal 8% jetzt sind 9,1 %
gewesen also etwas näher an dem
schlechtesten Ergebnis möglicherweise
hat man sich da mehr ausgerechnet
vielleicht lag es auch daran dass ich
natürlich im Ende in diesem Wahlkampf
alles fokussiert hat auf die großen Drei
die Kandidaten von SPD CDU und Bündnis
90 die Grünen aber wir wollen nicht zu
viel der Analyse vorwegnehmen sondern
das gemeinsam machen mit dem
Bundessprecher an der AFD die nur
Propeller
willkommen bei uns das Wahlergebnis von
gestern sind sie enttäuscht oder
zufrieden
ja es gibt erstmal zwei Gewinner der
gestrigen Wahl eine davon ist die AFD
gleichwohl hätten wir uns natürlich
gewünschten zweistelliges Ergebnis zu
erzielen aber wir konnten unsere
Stammwähler mobilisieren und wir haben
zugelegt also von daher ist das Positive
auch zu bewerten
ich frage jetzt mal andersrum selbst die
Wählerinnen und Wähler von Rot-Grün rot
würden nicht im Ernst behaupten dass der
Senat gut regiert hat die
regierungskunst in Berlin die changierte
ja so ein bisschen von unfreiwilliger
Komik bis Desaster mit allen
Schattierung der zwischen das ist
eigentlich die große Stunde des Protest
und vor allen Dingen der Opposition aber
davon wirklich profitiert hat nur die
CDU
ja es haben beide profitiert das muss
man sagen wenngleich die CDU mehr
Protest abgeschöpft hat dass es richtig
rot rot grün ist hier in Berlin klar
abgewählt worden trotzdem gibt es ja
wahrscheinlich die wünsche weiter zu
regieren mit dieser Konstellation also
hier zeigt sich auch ein Stück weit von
der CDU was Brandmauern bringen nämlich
nichts
die AFD ist scheint ja wie festgenagelt
zu sein in der Opposition sie sind jetzt
auf der Suche nach Bündnispartnern man
ist ja völlig überrascht man ist ja
richtig überrascht davon dass Tino
krupala jetzt mit alles schwarzer mit
Sarah Wagenknecht mit Margot Käßmann in
einem Boot sitzt und zwar für den
Frieden in der Ukraine zu rot und damit
sind sie gesellschaftlichen politisch
aber ziemlich gut und ziemlich breit
aufgestellt ja ich denke für den wenn
man für den Frieden einsteht egal mit
welcher Konstellationen hier geht's über
Partei Grenzen hinweg das muss das Ziel
sein wenn man für Frieden einsteht kann
man nie falsch sein da ist man immer auf
der richtigen Seite und von daher ist es
begrüßenswert dass Ali schwarzer und
auch Sarah Wagenknecht unsere
Friedensinitiative die wir im Übrigen
als erstes in den Deutschen Bundestag
eingebracht damit aufnehmen für ihre
Friedens in der Tiefe bzw für ihre
Petition und sie hat der großen und
breiten gesellschaftlichen anklagen
zwischen sie und Sahra Wagen nicht passt
ja kein Blatt Papier in Sachen Russland
und Ukraine würde es Sahra Wagenknecht
doch die Linke verlassen und eine eigene
parteikon dann wäre das schlecht für die
AFD in Ostdeutschland wissen Sie hier
geht es um Positionen und ich habe
gesagt eingangs gesagt hier geht es um
die friedensposition und ein großer Teil
der Bevölkerung möchte endlich dass
dieser Krieg beendet wird dass endlich
Diplomatie vor allem nehmen wolltet wie
als Friedenspartei haben das immer
wieder initiiert und auch vorangetrieben
dass man hier Diplomaten schickt und
keine Granaten das ist das Ziel und wer
sich wie gesagt diesen Aufruf auch
anschließt das ist begrüßen es wird dann
hier muss es Druck auf die
Bundesregierung geben denn dieser
Kriegskurs kann so nicht weitergehen und
die Granaten schickt er vor allen Dingen
Putin und das wird ja eigentlich korrekt
ja gut aber putin hatte einen
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
gestartet das sagen sie selbst die
Ukraine wehrt sich dagegen mit Hilfe
westlicher Waffen also die Einseitigkeit
dieses Aufrufs größte Gefahr geht von
einem Atomkrieg aus oder befürchtet man
ein Atomkrieg wenn die Ukraine sich die
Creme zurückholen die zu ihr gehört ist
eine etwas seltsame Positionierung ja
nochmal die Eskalation muss beendet
werden das Putin diesen Krieg begonnen
hat bzw dass er zumindestens für den
Einmarsch in der Ukraine verantwortlich
ist das ist ja gibt es ja keine zwei
Meinungen aber was ist eigentlich das
Ziel der strategische Ziel der NATO und
auch der Bündnispartner wenn man sich
hier hineinziehen lassen in diesen Krieg
das kann nicht unser aller Wille sein
wir wollen auch nicht noch Soldaten
schicken wir haben ja angefangen mit mit
Helmen die man geschickt hat damit
Panzern jetzt mittlerweile redet man
schon von Kampfjets also diese
Eskalationsspirale auch die Wünsche der
Ukraine hier zu bedienen die geht ja
immer weiter und davor warnen wir und
ich denke das sollten wir auch klar
machen es ist nicht unser Krieg und wir
wollen nicht in diesen Krieg
hineingezogen werden und ich halte auch
Äußerung von unserer Außenministerin
Frau bergerburg für höchst gefährlich
die er mittlerweile schon in Deutschland
in diesen Krieg mit Russland während
genauso die Kriegstreiberei von Frau
Zimmermann darf man aber wird man
wahrscheinlich kaum behaupten können
dass die Bundeswehr sich in diesen Krieg
hineinziehen lässt sich selbst kaum in
der Lage das eigene Land zu verteidigen
nach der Ausstellung ich würde aber
gerne auf eine andere Strategie noch
eingehen ich habe es gerade schon
angesprochen die koalitionspolitischen
Absichten der AFD im nächsten Jahr sind
in drei ostdeutschen Bundesländern
Landtagswahlen in zweien davon könnten
sie die stärkste parteiwand glauben Sie
dass die dortigen
cdu-landesverbände ihrem
bundesparteiische Friedrich Merz die
Hörner aufsetzen und trotz
Parteitagsbeschluss mit ihnen koalieren
wenn man den politischen Kurs zum
Beispiel für Michael Kretschmer in
Sachsen sieht dann hat er ja bereits
Friedrich Merz die Hörner aufgesetzt
sprichwörtlich also er fährt ein
komplett anderen Kurs wohl wissend dass
er natürlich für eine AFD hier stark
unter Druck steht wir sehen uns jetzt
aktuell in Berlin ist das beste Beispiel
eine super Blaupause was der CDU im
Endeffekt sie genutzten nämlich wenn es
darauf ankommt wahrscheinlich gar nicht
und dass man Koalitionspartner jenseits
der linken Seite braucht und da steht
die AFD gern bereit wenn man Politik
wirklich für den Bürger verändern will
und das muss ich die CDU einfach
klarmachen dann wird es an uns wird man
mit uns an uns nicht vorbeikommen und
das wird die CDU auch merken in den
restlichen Ländern
war ja ob sie das für möglich halten
ihre co-chefin alles Weidel ist ja noch
etwas mutiger die sagt jawohl nächstes
Jahr regieren wir mit na ich halte alles
Vermögen natürlich ist das unser Ziel am
Ende müssen wir regieren wenn wir hier
was verändern wollen man sieht es ja
dass man mit in der Opposition zwar
vieles anregen kann aber die Veränderung
kann man natürlich nur voranbringen wenn
man die Machtfrage stellt und das machen
wir heimatlose gibt es jetzt schon in
der CDU zum Beispiel Hans-Georg Maaßen
und seine werteunion öffnen Sie die Tür
für einen Eintritt dieser Leute in die
AFD wissen wir haben in unserer Partei
die Türen in alle Richtungen geöffnet
wir haben eine breite Wählerschicht und
wir haben es ja auch gesehen in den
Wähler Wanderung zu allen von allen
Parteien sind Wähler zu uns gekommen wir
wollen natürlich auch einen großen Teil
die nicht Wähler mobilisieren also von
daher programmatisch haben wir wichtige
Punkte im sozialen in der Außenpolitik
in der Innenpolitik Migrationspolitik
die viele Menschen in diesem Land
anspricht und ich denke dass wir damit
auch viele Wähler der anderen Parteien
aber auch eventuell alte Mitglieder
mobilisieren und interessieren zu uns
kommen die Frage zum Schluss aber hans-
als mutmaßlich fünfte Kolonne der AFD in
der CDU für Sie wahrscheinlich viel
wertvoller ja ich will jetzt über diese
diese werteunionshülle nicht diskutieren
oder nicht reden das ist Aufgabe der CDU
damit klarzukommen es sieht man sieht
aber dass die CDU an allen Rändern in
ihrer eigenen Programmatik und auch
ihrer Partei ausfranst und gleichwohl
wie gesagt haben wir programmatisch
viele Überschneidungen in vielen Punkten
ich habe es ja gerade erwähnt also für
diese Mitglieder und auch für diese für
dieses WLAN Milieu sind wir natürlich
offen das ist unsere Strategie dahin und
von daher bin ich auch gespannt wie sich
das weiter entwickelt
der Bundessprecher der AFD im Phoenix
Interview danke dass Sie daran
ja das war heute noch nicht alles von
der AFD um 11 Uhr ist
Pressekonferenz mit Tino krupala und der
Spitzenkandidatin bei der Berliner
Abgeordnetenhauswahl Christin Brinker
live bei Phoenix und jetzt geht's
erstmal zurück zu Stefan Kulle nach Bonn